يتصاعد القتال في اوكرانيا ويتصاعد ايذاءه
الحديث عن تكثيف الدعم الغربي منذ الاحد
يتحدث الجانب الروسي عن معارك عنيفه
يخوضها في مدينه سوليدار شمالي دونيتسك
والخسائر فادحه تكبدها الاوكرانيون ابرزها
سقوط بلده بخمود سكوين والاوكرانيون من
جهتهم ارسلوا تعزيزات لمدينه سوليدار
وقالوا ان الجيش الروسي قصفها خلال
الساعات الماضيه اكثر من 100 مره وشنف 22
هجوما سعيا الاتحامها وفقا ناطق الاوكراني
باسم قياده المنطقه الشرقيه فقد دمرت
مدينه السوليدار بشكل جزئي نتيجه الهجمات
الروسيه الاخيره بعد ان زجت موسكو باكثر
عناصر فاجنر خبره وتدريبا وحددتني نقاط
ضعف الدفاعات الاوكرانيه وضغطت عليها
يكفي فرصه اذا ضغطهم على جبهات القتال وفي
المقابل تتعالى دعوات غربيه للاحتشاد خلف
اوكرانيا هذه المره بتقديم اعتاد هجوميه
تدعو هولندا لتشكيل التحالف واسع لتزويد
اوكرانيا بالدبابات القتاليه الحديثه لعله
استعداد لحمله واسعه يواصل المسؤولون
الاوكرانيون التبشير بها كمغير مرتب وجذري
للموازين الميدانيه تحدثت اطراف مغربيه
عده عن امدادات للدبابات والمدرعات للحليب
الاوكراني تدرس بريطانيا تزويد اوكرانيا
بدبابات قتاليه من طراز شالنجر اثنين التي
تزن 62 طنا ونصف الطن ومزوده بمدفع معيار
120 مليمترا وكانت الولايات المتحده اعلنت
قبل ايام عن تقديم مساعدات العسكريه جديده
لاوكرانيا تتضمن عربات قتاليه امريكيه من
طراز برادلي التي تزن اكثر من سبعه وعشرين
من ومزوده بمدفع من عيار 25 ملم وصواريخ
خارقه للدروع ويمكن ان تعمل كناقله جند
كما اعلنت فرنسا ارسال مركبات قتاليه
مدرعه خفيفه من طراز اي ام اكس 10 ار سي
المزوده بمدفع من عيار 150 ملم والتي تسير
على عجلات مما يجعلها السهله الحركه وكذلك
يناقش المسؤولون في المانيا امداد كيف
بدبابات قتاليه ومدرعات من طراز ماردر
التي يبلغ عيار مدفعها الاوتوماتيكي 25
ملليمترا يقلل الروس من اهميه هذه
الامدادات العسكريه الغربيه لاوكرانيا
ويرونها لن تكون قادره على اي تغيير جذري
لكن سكرتيره مجلس الامن الروسي كولايب
باتروسيف يضيفه ان بلاده لا تحاربه
اوكرانيا بالهيه في مواجهه الان مع نيته
وعلى راسه الولايات المتحده وبريطانيا وهو
حلف اتهمه المسؤول الروسي باستهدا اضعاف
بلاده وتدمير هذه اي ثمن على المدى البعيد